[Música]
i
aquí
buenas tardes
[Aplausos]
qué bonito es estar aquí en tepic
nayarit les cuento que no es mi primera
vez es como mi cuarta vez venir aquí
pero muy contentos muy contentos en
estar aquí en el programa de télex
tenemos pocos minutos para hacer una
buena presentación y lo que yo quiero
que se lleven de esta presentación es de
que todo es posible en la vida de que se
vale soñar en grande y yo amigos les voy
a contar una historia una forma muy
grande total donde les voy a dar la
herramienta de cómo convertir sueños a
la realidad
y entonces para poder hacer eso
para poder poder hacer esto hay que hay
que iniciar mi historia mucho antes de
que yo nací más bien es cuando nacieron
cuando vino mi papá a eeuu por primera
vez él tenía 15 años él viene de
michoacán
la piedad michoacan y entonces él desde
los 15 años pues él no más sabía
trabajar en la agricultura y en busca de
un trabajo mejor pagado hizo lo que
hacían muchos michoacanos y se iba a
california en las cosechas a seguir las
cosechas se iniciaba en el sur de
california norte de cali fue al centro
california y luego norte de california y
se regresaba
a la piedad por tres meses y repetir el
proceso
bueno creció
y a los 18 años conoce a mi mamá doña
julia
y entonces doña julia también es de la
piedad bueno en realidad no somos la
piedad somos siempre decimos que somos
de una ciudad grande cerca de donde
vivimos verdad porque realmente son de
un ranchito se llama ticuítaco y de allí
son entonces a los 18 hay en ticuítaco
se conoce a mi mamá
se comprometen y el próximo año llega
con sus dólares en la mano para casarse
con mi mamá y mi mamá tenía todos sus 14
años cuando se casaron mi papá 19 ella
14 muy chistoso porque la primera vez
que yo di esa conferencia en frente de
mis papás pues algo y corriendo yo a la
casa para ver qué reacción tenían ellos
mi papá le encantó mi mamá también le
encantó pero me dijo hijo te puedo dar
una sugerencia sí claro mami si la
próxima vez que cuentes esa historia y
llegues a la parte donde nos casamos sí
mamá y en voz baja dice les puedes decir
que tenía 15 años deja de mamá aún se ve
mal
aún se ve
a un ser humano bueno el genoma
mantenido en 14 es la neta así que bueno
se casaron y mi papá incorpora mi alma a
la corrida
de las cosechas y en eso viene la
familia y recuerden que eran nueve meses
en california tres meses en méxico así
que
cuando nacía el país que le tocaba a uno
dependía en qué mes
y todos los que saben de probabilidad
saben que de 9 de 12 chanzas 9 pueden
hacer en los estados unidos y 3 en
méxico yo gane esa chance así y nací en
eeuu porque nací en plena cosecha en
agosto otro hermano nació en septiembre
también nació en plena cosecha y allá
nació pero tengo un hermano y una
hermana que nacieron en allí en la
piedad bueno así es como crecimos y
nuestra vida siempre ha sido así en la
vida que yo conocí de pequeño era de ir
a tres diferentes escuelas en un año
escolar porque íbamos a tres distintas
ciudades dos meses dos meses cinco meses
y luego nos íbamos a mexico
y nos llevamos tres meses de tarea y
allí en la cocina de mi abuela mi mamá
nos ponía de lunes a viernes
de 8 de la mañana a mediodía auto
estudiábamos con una taza de chocolate o
un bolillo y eso sí la tarea manchada
del chocolate pero la hacíamos
las cosas no mejoraron a lo mejor
hasta que una maestra finalmente
convenció a mi papá
a que se quede en un solo lugar
y el el ejemplo que es que uso mi
maestra que uso mi maestra fue algo tan
interesante que se los comparto porque
mi papá no comprendía eso de que de que
nos teníamos que quedar en un lugar el a
pesar de que tenía una educación de
tercer grado de primaria igual que mi
mamá creía en la educación y de lunes a
viernes en la escuela eso sí el sábado y
domingo se llegaba y en el campo en la
pizca con mis papás y los veranos siete
días a la semana en el lápiz acá pero él
nos metía en la escuela y el ejemplo que
usó mi mamá mi maestra fue algo muy
simple como un día que no captaba el
mensaje mi papá asume un ejemplo muy muy
útil le dio un ejemplo de que le dijo
mire señor
haga de cuenta que le voy a regalar yo
cuatro arbolitos frutales en maceta y
envío para dijo está bien dijo quiero
que encuentre el terreno más fértil
y quiero que los plantes los cuatro
arbolitos pero en tres meses
quiero que escarbó otros cuatro hoyos y
trasplante esos arbolitos y en estos
tres meses es más cada tres meses
trasplante sus arbolitos a un lugar y
que no les falte nada el agua y
fertilizante usted dígame qué le pasa a
lo largo de sus arbolitos mi papá se
quedó pensando y dijo bueno no se vana
secar no se van a morir pero eso sí les
digo se van a quedar chicos y débiles
porque la raíz nunca crece profundo
y si son frutales hasta tal vez
disfrutan en
y cuando dijo eso puedes contar 123
cambias la pasión y como dicen en mi
rancho le cayó el veinte a mi papá
desde ese entonces ya no íbamos a méxico
por tres meses más tres semanas y el
único lugar que llegaban los era en el
norte de california han estado en
california allí es cuando empezó a ganar
tracción nuestra educación porque ya
estábamos en un solo lugar pero aún así
uno dice como como rayos un niño
campesino sueña quiere ser astronauta y
ese sueño
nace en 1972 cuando tenía 10 años tengo
55 para que no se quiebre en la cabeza
están y se notan contra 72 10 años
cuando te estamos 55
si ustedes pueden marginar imaginar un
niño en frente de una televisión blanca
y negra agarrando la antena oreja de
conejos con el tejido de la abuela abajo
viendo los últimos imágenes de la última
misión a todos 17 cuando el humano
caminó en la luna
eso era yo desde 1972 el humano no ha
regresado a la luna pero yo estaba
viendo esos imaginas
y luego salía veía arriba y estaba la
luna
[Música]
entraba
y miraba instrumento que recordó su
nombre astronautas jim zorn
hablando con mi gente entró houston todo
el recuerdo el reporte de walter blanca
y narrando todo eso
y yo dije de allí soy yo yo quiero ser
astronauta y lo mejor que pude haber
hecho es compartir ese sueño con mi papá
esa misma noche que le dije papá y hacen
lo que quiero ser cuando seas grande y
el mío si mi hijo que astronauta
se me queda viendo lo saqué de onda y me
dice mi hijo vamos a la cocina yo viene
asustado
sé que me va a regañar y me sienta donde
me sienta mi mamá para hacer la tarea
cada día después de la escuela y me hace
justificar porque quiero ser astronauta
ya le justificó todo lo que aprendí esa
noche
y yo creo que él vio la determinación de
un niño de 10 años que lo que me
sorprendió fue lo que me dijo después
esto es el poder de empoderar a tu hijo
a creer que todo es posible porque me
dijo si puedes hacerlo pero si quieres
hacerlo tienes que seguir esta receta de
cinco ingredientes al pie de la letra
hijo mira primero
primero
determina qué quieres ser pp cuando sea
grande segundo
reconoce que tan lejos estás de esa meta
tercero me dijo crear una ruta aún un
mapa para saber cómo llegar
le digo cuál es el cuarto para para el
estudio y la preparación
y quinto apuntó hacia afuera de la
cocina digo sabes el esfuerzo que pones
los sábados y domingos siete días de la
semana en el verano a las pizcas de la
verdura y frutas de los y papá apunta a
mis libros
con ese esfuerzo aquí
y cuando termines y trabajes me dijo
cerró la conversación con éste
con esta frase dijo siempre entrega más
de lo que la gente espera de ti siempre
entregan más
yo me acosté y dije wow bien contento
porque mi papá piensa que puedo ser
astronauta y lo voy a hacer yo lo único
que le agrego es un sexto ingrediente
y esa es la perseverancia la
perseverancia amigos porque yo estoy
aquí para decirles que la nasa me
rechazó no una vez no dos veces ni tres
veces fueron 11 veces no fue hasta la
doceava vez que la nasa me aceptó como
parte de la generación número 19 de
astronautas
y durante esas fallas yo encontré que
hay tres etapas para llegar a tu meta la
primera etapa es requisitos mínimos
hay que saber cuáles son los requisitos
minutos para llegar a tu meta si quieres
ser el doctor sabes que tienes que ir a
la escuela medicina pasar los exámenes
el doctor igualmente abogado ingeniero
astronauta igualmente en carrera de
ciencias posgrados cinco años de
experiencia y puedes meter tu aplicación
tu solicitud el problema es que más de
14.000 personas también llenaban esos
requisitos y es cuando encontré yo la
segunda etapa para llegar a las metas la
segunda etapa es comparte a las personas
a las que son exitosas a como tú quieres
ser y pregúntate y ser honesto contigo
que tienen ellos que yo no tengo la
primera vez que yo hice eso miré que
tenían el mismo estudio experiencia pero
es como pelar una cebolla y encontrar
más adentro buscarle y miré piloto
piloto piloto piloto yo no era piloto
pues se invertían en mí mismo y me
convertí en piloto otro año piloto
piloto piloto piloto bien contento
pero luego pelando la cebolla buceador
buceador buceador y yo que la frente
aunque ese buceador
me certifique buceador básico buceador
ha avanzado buscador de rescate buceador
maestro quería que la nasa supiera que
sabía bucear
esa es la segunda etapa
comparte con la gente que ya está allí y
trata de ser como ellos
la tercera etapa hay que sobresalir de
la competencia
y eso me vino a mí porque yo trabajaba
con el gobierno americano me invitaron a
trabajar en rusia ayuda a los rusos
controlar su material nuclear
y nadie quería ir y yo dije yo sí voy
nadie quería ir porque se involucraba un
compromiso cinco años viajaba seis siete
veces al año tres semanas a rusia
ayudando a los rusos pero como era mucho
viaje nadie quería y yo dije yo sí voy
porque porque fui estratégico yo había
leído en las noticias que rusia y éstas
nos habían firmado un acuerdo para
para construir lo que iba a ser la
estación espacial internacional los
húmedos y dos y dije que son cuatro si
trabajó con los rusos se va a ver mucho
mejor en mi perfil con la nasa y es más
cuando y con mi jefe y decido y jefe
póngame un maestro para poder aprender
ruso y ya con mayo para rosquillas y que
aprendí ruso
ustedes son mi perfil que creen ahora si
me hablaba la nasa me entrevistó y todo
aún así batalla tres veces en la lista
de 100 finalistas y no fue hasta la
doceava ves que finalmente fui
seleccionado
después de 11 rechazos la doceava vez
fue cuando fui seleccionado eso es
perseverancia si me permiten les quiero
enseñar con compartir un vídeo de mi
misión espacial porque me seleccionan
2004 en 2000 tenía que entrenar dos años
antes ser elegible por una misión
espacial y luego en 2007 me asignan el
vuelo otro año y medio de entrenamiento
y en 2009 es cuando nos lanzamos agosto
28 les comparto este vídeo por favor
ese es el escudo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
éramos una tripulación de siete
astronautas yo era el ingeniero de vuelo
somos cuatro en la cabina de vuelo y
tres en en la cabina
de abajo nuestra tripulación era
tripulación internacional aquí está
christer fuglesang un sueco el compañero
ingeniero que está abriendo las puertas
de sobrecarga para iniciar la
calefacción
aquí está su servidor poniendo las
computadoras que nos van a ayudar a
juntarnos con la estación espacial
internacional mientras otros arreglan
equipo de ejercicio para no sufrir
atrofia muscular en el espacio ustedes
niñas que quieren ser astronautas aquí
está mi colega nicole stott una colega
ingeniera está viendo lo que va a ser su
casa por los próximos tres meses porque
la vamos a dejar allí esta es la vista
de los astronautas en la estación
espacial internacional de nosotros
estamos dando una maroma para que nos
inspección en el sistema de protección
termal que tenemos abajo porque así
perdimos una nave la colombia por daños
que sufrió y al / se desea explotó
este cilindro tiene más de 7 toneladas
de equipo que vamos a entregar a la
estación espacial durante los 14 días de
vuelo que estamos haciendo
aquí estamos en los momentos antes de
conectarnos físicamente a la estación
espacial
aquí estamos celebrando eso nos permite
que podemos abrir
en la puerta de acceso para entonces
poder entrar a la estación espacial
internacional
recuerden nosotros somos siete
tripulantes del transbordador y nos
están esperando seis astronautas en la
estación espacial o sea 13 astronautas a
la vez en el espacio
representando oficialmente cinco países
sigo oficialmente cinco países porque
también méxico está bien representado
allí con su servidor y ellos muy
contentos en vernos no porque somos
buenos camaradas pero porque saben que
tenemos verduras frescas y fruta fresca
si nos hacen la barba para compartir esa
comida aquí estamos vaciando los 7
toneladas de equipo del mol del pp subir
sets mayor y luego también instalamos
equipo en el exterior del transbordador
vía caminatas grupos de dos realizan
caminatas en el exterior de la estación
espacial internacional donde instalamos
antenas sistemas de gps
a pompas de jamón ya en fin muchas cosas
que hacemos en el mantenimiento a la
estación espacial
después de esos 13 de los 14 días en el
espacio ya nos desconectamos de la
estación espacial
ahora nos toca darle una vuelta
alrededor del mundo nosotros hay bueno
alrededor de la estación espacial para
tomarle fotos de alta de resolución todo
esto mientras estamos dándole vueltas
nosotros al mundo una vez cada 90
minutos porque lanzamos de 0 kilómetros
por hora a 25.000 kilómetros por hora en
8 minutos y medio para llegar al espacio
a 400 kilómetros de altura y luego
giramos alrededor del mundo a esa
velocidad de 25.000 kilómetros por hora
una vez cada 90 minutos y entonces ya
nos despegamos de la estación dejamos
que el amo sola nos capture y entramos
como un aeroplano recuerden que salimos
como cohete lo convertimos una nave
espacial ahora es un aeroplano
aterrizamos en el sur de california no
tan lejos donde yo pescaba fresas de
niño en el western for space nuestro
comandante como un buen marinero piloto
aterriza mucho más mejor que mi
aterrizaje acá en guadalajara de united
y así es una misión amigos solamente les
quiero hablar el resumen de la receta
porque creo que es muy importante
recuerden la receta de mi papá cinco
ingredientes decidan lo que quieran
hacer en la vida reconozcan que tan
lejos están crean una ruta para saber
llegar
prepárense con educación esfuerzo
échenle ganas no se den por vencidos
perseverancia y las tres etapas se
reconozcan los requisitos mínimos para
llegar vean los que ya llegaron y
aprendan de ellos
y hagan cosas para sobresalir de la
competencia ponen todo eso en trabajo yo
les hago el mismo la misma promesa que
me hizo mi papá a mí de que ustedes
pueden alcanzar sus propias estrellas
muchísimas gracias muchas gracias
si me permiten un safin
[Aplausos]
a todos a todos
muchas gracias
[Música]